[Musique]
pourquoi je peux payer les 1 100 des
mois si tout copieusement jeudi que le
privé tu vas pas aimé c'est tout propre
c'est tout net a rien qui dépasse t elle
et revient mais non
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu fous que la dame les
enfants les thèmes de la cantine
voudrais savoir qui est en situation
d'arabité pigmentaire approbation
musulmane qui mange du cochon il était
malade tu as attendu non en fait on a
enlevé de l'école remettra dans le noir
on veut ce qu'il ya de mieux pour nos
gosses pas c'est normal
écoutez le remplacer le sel de la classe
sl quoi c'est le blanc tu me dises à moi
en plus
riscle et la mixité pour que ce soit la
nécessité pour ce soit de la mixité si
ça n'est pas la mixité ça n'est pas de
la mixité tu vois voici saint-benoît
notre protecteur mais l'école est aussi
accessible aux non croyants
alors moi je suis avocate et lui et
musiciens professionnels
je vois que vous avez fait un clip
[Musique]
aujourd'hui le match de lens
c'est quand il y a plus d'école pour les
gens comme nous tu ne supportes persane
tu fout de la gueule de tout le monde je
crois en rien encore tout fait fort avec
des principes de mes nos enfants il en
vache mans besoin de nous ils vous
reprochent pas vous attend ce
commentaire
pour madame jeanne gamins qui ne va pas
bien là vous comprenez pas je suis
affaire de merde en ce moment
eh bien il avec ses copains j'ai des
gens comme vous semblez quand on est
foutu là
c'est à dire personne ne leur culot
censure culé le pape mais surtout il est
surtout à la batterie voilà puis les
paroles aussi je pensais pas des paroles